hi there steve here doing things a
little differently
tonight we have this nice print of a van
gogh van hawk
painting of a cafe
actually i'll move away from it so you
can see it of a cafe i think in all in
southern france cafe de nuit
um i'm going to report today i'm going
to talk about input and output and
grammar and i'm going to refer to the
american council
of teachers of foreign languages
convention in boston where i spent
three
three and a half great days
a major theme there was the issue of
input
authentic input
presenters talked about different kinds
of authentic input
ads like advertisements or
i don't know
wrappings of product or anything could
be authentic uh content
the importance of input stephen krashen
was there spoke he was him
and uh bill van patten were by far the
most popular speakers people were
cramming the aisles to listen to them
speak
and he was as usual very persuasive
stephen krashen was about the importance
of compelling
input that if we have compelling
messages compelling
uh comprehensible input people will
learn
and both he and bill van patten
explain that that the grammar as an
attempt to describe what happens in a
language is is not very successful
because first of all what happens in a
language is very subtle
very deep in a way and it's not possible
to explain it and from the learner's
perspective it's very difficult to
remember the explanation to think of it
when you go to use it
to apply it and that really we learn
primarily through input and that our
accuracy in using the language
is not is something that comes after a
lot of input is not because we use the
language accurately that we then acquire
the language we first acquire the
language and then we find that we're
increasingly able to use it accurately i
very much believe in that concept
um
there was uh some comment uh
on my last video where one of a
commenter who is a classroom teacher got
very upset he thinks krashen has spoiled
language instruction
because of his insistence on input over
grammar instruction
but my impression in talking to
i don't know how many tens and tens of
teachers
was that lip service still is paid to
the idea of input and that the curricula
the school boards even the parents still
insist on more of a grammar-based method
of instruction which really isn't that
successful when they wander away from
that results improve i attended for
example a presentation by a group of
university teachers of japanese i think
it was smith college and
university of massachusetts amherst
and they had a program which in japanese
is known as tadoku like read a lot
and they measured the students and they
found that the students liked it and
that they spent a lot of time reading
rather than the more conventional
method of instruction that they ended up
doing better which is similar to the
research that krashen
and others have done to demonstrate the
advantage of an input based method of
instruction
um i went to amongst the different
places that i visited but it was very
exciting seven thousand people all of
them if it was a presentation in french
the teachers the french teachers many of
whom were
english-speaking uh americans
were very very fluent in french or in
spanish
again very exciting to be with with
people who are motivated and who are
committed to what they're doing
there was a presentation for example by
a group of korean teachers
uh talking about a program they'd set up
whereby students i think it was yale
princeton i don't know where else they
could connect with seniors in korea and
therefore converse in korean so i
listened to this in korea and then i
stood up in korean and said i'm a senior
but i'm learning korean can i be part of
the program and of course they said no
because you have to be a student
at one of their schools
uh what else was it there was a
presentation by the university of san
diego again by ms marianne
uh
lyman hagar whom i've often quoted
because of her insight into what i call
the three keys of language learning in
other words
uh you the attitude of the learner the
time with the language and your ability
to notice and they presented this
marvelous
um
interactive
uh multimedia presentation on french
civilization and explained how it would
be used in the classroom and stuff and
so there's lots of of interesting uh
presentations to go to
uh there were some i was listening to
one by a chinese professor explaining
the subtle differences between
this expression and that expression in
chinese and how the teacher could
explain this and all kinds of detail and
i felt that again that
really the differences are so subtle
that there's no way you can explain it
it's again through
massive input that you start to get a
feel for how these different
expressions are used
but language language is culture like
here again you know you think of french
civilization van gaal van gogh is of
course a dutch painter but he became
involved in the artistic scene in france
this is al in 1888
language connects us with so many
different things and i was experiencing
that
there in in boston speaking lots of
different languages i was surprised how
underrepresented russian as a language
was because it's one of the major
languages of the world
we had i met someone teaching swahili
the koreans were active latin and so
forth and really russian was not very
active at all i think that's really a
pity
i'm involved in organizing the
montreal language festival in august i
hope we do a better job of presenting
some of these other languages including
russian
uh farsi too one day for me i hope
um anyway that's basically it uh to me
input is the way to go that's not to say
that you don't spend some time reviewing
grammar with or without a teacher
uh that you don't have to eventually
output a lot you eventually have to
speak a lot but the way you ramp up your
skills you ramp up your familiarity with
the language you develop the potential
to speak well is through massive input
listening and reading and my experience
in boston confirmed that for me so thank
you for listening and that's all i have
to say and now i have to get back to
seriously get back to my korean
challenge bye for now